Speaker 1: Let's go next to Grant from Iowa
City.
Grant, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind?
Speaker 4: Hey, David.
Great.
Great to talk with you again.
Speaker 1: Likewise.
Speaker 4: So if you would like to have a
variety of different perspectives, I hear
from in many areas of life just to, like further
develop my own ideas about how I truly feel
about things.
And I also think it's good to learn how people
feel about a given topic so that I can empathize
with them better and connect with them better.
But I usually don't have an issue doing this
except when it comes to politics.
I have a hard time finding anyone who's really
interesting or valuable.
Listen to on the right.
I was just wondering if you had anyone you
can think of that would be like, come on,
like I guess worth listening to, because I
find usually they're either ignorant or only
arrogant or even just rude, perhaps.
And I just it's kind of a waste of time, but
I would like to actually now engage with some
ideas that I disagree with.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: I don't have anybody specific.
I mean.
Well, so is there a particular issue on which
you would like such a person?
Speaker 4: But not really, I guess.
I think just in general.
Speaker 1: General right winger.
I don't know.
I wish I had someone to recommend, but I really
don't at this point in time.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I wasn't sure if you.
Well, I know you're busy doing your own thing,
but.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's just because and I have
a fair number of, you know, close relatives
and friends who are conservative, but yeah,
they don't get too involved politically.
And so it kind of like, well, they don't really
think through the issues too much.
It's kind of just, you know, their gut reaction
to things based on whatever their upbringing
or their.
Yeah.
Theological views or whatever.
But.
Speaker 1: And do you like engaging with those
people, or is it more of an annoyance?
Speaker 4: I enjoy it.
It's just I feel like we don't really get
down to the nitty gritty of stuff because
it's pretty surface level.
And the minute I start trying to talk about
something more deeper level, they either get
kind of lost in it or they just lose interest
or yeah, whatever.
I mean, as far as actual political commentators
I've tried listening to, like Ben SHAPIRO
and it's like it's pretty painful.
Yeah.
Name on the right.
But I just like, can't really do it.
Speaker 1: So yeah, no, I don't blame you.
I mean, you know, what I would suggest is,
rather than just like finding that stuff,
find some, like, find some books that maybe
would give you a more sensible panorama on
some of these right wing ideologies from like
more traditional conservatives.
I still don't really know exactly who I'd
recommend, but I would go that direction rather
than trying to figure out, you know, by listening
to Ben SHAPIRO.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Yeah.
No.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend.
Thank you for the call.
Speaker 4: Okay.
All right.
Speaker 1: Very good.
There is Grant.
Very, very strong.
Let's go next to let's go to Elias from Pennsylvania.
Elias, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hey, David, I haven't called in
a while.
Speaker 1: How are you?
I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 3: I have been listening to a whole
bunch of leftist streamers recently, and the
idea I've been getting is that we need a more
cohesive online left to take advantage of,
you know, the Gen-Z voter base that showed
itself most recently.
And we don't really have a cohesive message.
And I was wondering if you had any ideas for
gathering the online left to have a more,
you know, online a stronger online community?
Speaker 1: You know, the reason that this
is really tough is that by definition, the
left is a little more fractured in that we,
I feel, are more resistant to just wanting
to be part of, like, one big tent to some
degree because.
We often allow the perfect to become the enemy
of the good.
And what I don't like sometimes seeing on
the left is people who are aligned on 90%
of issues saying, I can't be with this person
or that person in the same coalition because
of the five or 10% on which we differ.
And I think that that fundamentally gets in
the way of building the bigger consensus like
you're talking about.
I would love to see that to a great degree.
I don't know who would organize it.
And I think that there's something about the
left that is more antithetical to welcoming
and accepting that.
So I'd have to devote some more thought to
it.
I love the idea.
I think the left needs to be better organized.
I just don't know exactly what the hub or
the crux of it would be.
Hello.
Well.
I guess he's gone.
Okay, that was.
That was weird